I said I used to kill it like he used to
use it past I know he's killing it now
but like even but I mean you have to
imagine a guy who you know you don't
really know his name but you just know
when he walks into a commercial you know
auditioning room you go oh [ __ ] that guy
but I feel that people thought that
about me I think they do I think they do
because I've heard other people say yes
those who used to come in and he used to
get it and then you know men I hope and
they never get nice there were guys that
didn't get would go in and never got any
yeah so you imagine going in to 50 of
them and then seeing you at half of them
and then you're on half of those in his
head he's like that guy's a beast but
there were people like that when I moved
out here that I would see in every
commercial yeah I would walk in it took
a while for me to get to be considered
that guy God you really humble or not I
am I think say you are yeah what were
you doing immediately before you got
cast on Modern Family um commercials
like mostly just commercials I had done
a few guest stars leading up in that
year on TV shows where I had killed
killed a few people Bobby knows my dark
side yeah but he also was on movies like
almost famous it was in that yeah a
small part yep it's do yeah I'm you have
to imagine when I was watching that
movie back in the day yeah
but I was in one of my down you know
like little thunks as an actor right
before modern family you know how we go
through those things where you're just
like well what do I do now and I was
literally in one of those in a friend of
mine who I met through Joe Pitka
Marshall Bell I don't know if you ever
worked with Marshall Bell he's a
character actor talks like this he's
from Oklahoma makes his teeth a lot and
I called him and I was like dude I'm
having he's like what else you gonna do
man you got traction you're in the
business you got to stay whoa
he talked me he like talked me down off
the good ledge he's like what else can
you do well Jesus I guess when you put
it that way yeah so and then the
audition for Modern Family happened like
within that form a four-month window of
that period and I
that that whole audition process was a
long one for you where they kind of
didn't know like who they wanted to cast
is that your girlfriend's so much
smarter than you she seems good yeah
yeah yeah okay okay yeah okay we'll take
the [ __ ] stocky cap and all that so
yeah it was well because I was one of
the last people that they had cast in
the show they had been looking for a
while and I did you know for auditions
for which isn't that that unusual but
what made my process a little more
unusual was that they had done two
auditions and they had passed like sent
word that like they liked me but it
wasn't gonna go any further
mm-hm because I had knew I knew the
casting director and so it was a
courtesy call for him calling my manager
cuz you know as actors we'd love to know
when we're no longer and so we're not
sitting home wondering so he just called
and said hey you know they really like
Derek but it's not it's not gonna go any
further twice they did that to me oh my
god so that was what made my process for
me a little different and then then you
then the third time did you go I'm not
gonna go back in or well no then they
called out of the blue and said we'll
test you so then so I went at once
passed then 10 days 7 days passed and
they called back and said come back in
dress more appropriately for the
character clean shaven cuz I would roll
around that's another thing I was I
loved about you yeah I would never like
dirty play the play the game of doctors
coat oh yeah I like I used to get when I
first moved into town like the only
Asian one so I'd go to a lobby and saw
people in ninja suits yeah
and samurai swords and I would dress
like this yeah I knew it was time for me
to start getting thinking about getting
out of the commercial business when I
went over to an audition in Santa Monica
yeah and it called for a guy in a suit
and tie and I showed up you know just in
like a nice shirt and jeans yeah I
wasn't looking like a slob and the guy
was like oh what are you here for
and I said Sears
he's like where's your suit and tie and
I said oh do they have the set build in
there too he's like what I said did they
build the set do we is the set in there
yeah
did it have no imagination yeah yeah
yeah so I was like I need to back away
I'm loose well twelve years of this has
come but anyway I was just doing
commercials and I remember distinct
distinctly shooting the pilot and
listening to all my co-stars talking
about their careers and the things that
they had and that includes the kids on
the show and everyone had something that
they were either going to do if the show
didn't get picked up or that they had
turned down to do the show like Julie
Bowen was in second position on another
pilot Ty Burrell was in second position
on another pilot Sofia Vergara had a
holding deal at ABC Jesse Tyler Ferguson
was going to go to Broadway and play
buddy the elf in the musical elf Mario
winter who's a brilliant actress she had
something that she was going to do Rico
was like killing it yeah doing his own
thing everybody had something going on
and I really remember sitting there
thinking I have a Lowe's callback yeah
but that was my that was my career up in
that to that point and I think I
represented so many actors to that point
I was the guy who I was the least known
adult for sure
maybe Ariel and Sarah Hyland were more
recognizable I mean they'd worked more
than I had almost probably and that's
yeah but can I just say this the
argument is this though I don't you said
all those names I don't know who do you
don't watch the show I doesn't matter
wait a minute what no I don't know see
that you've never seen modern face okay
he's pretty great [ __ ] I know it's
good [ __ ] is it too hard for you
after you were clip it's I saw one time
you did that thing we reached the baby
up and you did a a lion king thing that
was supposed to be you Bobby went over I
saw the hassed on him twice
no I saw that you know how you you're
I'm like because that's like Coach and I
had one of those little TV screens and
somebody was next to me seeing that part
and then laughing I want to say that's
my friend you know man but I didn't but
I laughed because the way you did was
funny and that's all indicee but when i
want to say this he has a hard time
watching my son either
i can't see any but not even yourself
but your friends you all right just
can't do it okay but just can I just say
this sure is that I don't know they are
that's fine I know the guy from married
with children he's in it at Ted Bundy's
a murderer's but I can I and people that
were in the comedy business right know
who you are and we think that you were
we were always thought I always thought
that we were legit yeah and that's what
I give a [ __ ] about yeah well that's
like when like um you know one time I
was at Barnes & Noble and this is before
I met you sweetie and I was with this
girl at the shitty date yeah and Chris
Rock walked up and said what's up dude
give me a hug and that's I don't care
about if the variety you mean knows me
or whatever I just care that that dude
who's in the same business as I am
respects me or knows who I am I mean so
I'd rather have that
[Music]